the last British royal wedding between
Prince William and Kate Middleton
brought together nineteen hundred guests
many of whom were pretty high-profile
people footballer David Beckham was
there with his wife and fashion designer
Victoria Beckham Elton John was there
too but this photo might be the most
impressive of all because this is the
Queen of Spain and the Prince of Spain
next to the princess of Sweden the
former king of Greece is behind them and
way back there is the former king of
Romania they were invited because
they're all related to Prince William's
great-great-great great-grandmother
Queen Victoria over the course of her 63
year reign she strategically planned
marriages to place her descendants and
royal families all over Europe and in
doing so created one of the most
remarkable royal families in history
[Music]
by the early 19th century Europe had
been at war for decades after the French
revolutionary and Napoleonic Wars killed
millions European leaders came together
to restore peace by reshaping major
States for a new balance of power
Great Britain went on to become one of
the strongest States and years later
Queen Victoria and her husband Albert
came up with a plan to maintain that
political power they married their
children to monarchs across Europe and
at that time you know all royal
marriages were fundamentally about
dynastic unions about cementing
political allegiances about building new
political alliances it started with
their daughter Vicky the eldest of nine
children she married the heir to the
Prussian throne the largest and most
powerful of the German states Albert's
vision had always been a victorious
shared it that Prussia of all the German
states was the one that would end up
leading the way towards a great unified
Germany they wanted to build strong
connections with Germany and see them as
being a force for good and
constitutional benign monarchy across
Europe their children Alice Beatrice
Helena Leopold and Arthur also married
German royalty their eldest son Prince
Albert Edward married a Danish princess
whose brother was the king of Greece two
more important European states but when
their son Alfred wanted to marry the
daughter of the Russian Tsar things
became a bit more complicated there was
a long history about Queen Victoria's
deeply apprehensions about Russia for
any of her children marrying into Russia
the Russian monarchy was an autocracy
whereas the the British monarchy as such
was a constitutional monarchy there was
a whole long period of russophobia in
Britain the two states were also
extremely competitive over territory in
Central Asia and Eastern Europe where
they fought a bloody war in the 1850s
but the marriage was allowed and by the
1880s Queen Victoria's children were in
several important branches of Europe's
monarchies but did it bring peace to
Europe
not quite see Germany did unify in 1871
but it wasn't peaceful Prussia fought a
series of bloody wars and consolidated
the other German states in Russia the
Royal Romanov family was losing its grip
on power members of the monarchy were
being hunted and the Tsar was
assassinated in 1881 the royal unions
didn't play out as Queen Victoria
planned but she continued to make more
matches anyway she had 42 grandchildren
in total and these seven ended up on
Royal Thrones the eldest wilhelm ii who
was already in line to be the next
emperor of Germany mérida German
princess in 1881 the hope was that he
would steer a unified and powerful
Germany into an alliance with Great
Britain George was in line to be the
king of Great Britain and married a
minor British royal family member
Alexandra married Nicholas who was
related to George and Wilhelm and both
became the Tsar and czarina of Russia
and for more granddaughters married in
European royalty fulfilling Victoria's
vision I mean when you look at Queen
Victoria by the end of her life she
really was the grandmother of Europe
take for example this family photo where
Queen Victoria's with her daughter and
grandson the rulers of Germany her son
Britain's Next King and her
granddaughters the future czarina of
Russia and the future queen of Romania
here's the soon-to-be King of England
and his look-alike cousin the soon-to-be
Tsar of Russia and here's some of the
children and grandchildren together
finally this is King Edward of Great
Britain and his nephew Kaiser Wilhelm of
Germany at Queen Victoria's funeral in
1901 after her death the family ties
that Queen Victoria had strung around
Europe would not bring peace but the
most destructive war Europe had ever
seen the king of Gotham ban make ready
to sweep the field
zarab Russia mobilizes England joins the
battle royal World War one broke out in
1914 and split this family apart
Wilhelm's Germany along with Austria
Hungary and the Ottoman Empire fought an
alliance led by Britain Russia and
France these countries were neutral say
Victoria had lived till we were on the
brink before I think it would have
broken up totally broken her heart to
know that her grandchildren ended up at
war with each other the war killed over
10 million people and ended the era of
monarchy in Europe Wilhelm Sophia and
Maria Rolfe forced to abandon their
Thrones revolution swept through Russia
and Alexandria and Nicholas were
executed by communists the British
monarchy survived but the war forced
them to rethink their political strategy
George King George the fed and his wife
B Mary were very very astute they saw
that the monarchy had to be more
people-friendly had to be more
accessible not just sitting there in
great robes in glory you know with their
crowns on had to be much more out on the
street and so on meet the people win
their confidence Carney monarchy we now
have with Queen Elizabeth that approach
not only helped modernize British
monarchy over the last century but it
also changed the face of royal weddings
forever
[Music]